[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le mardi 8 février voici
les titres 40 % des créateurs
d'entreprises en france étaient des
femmes en 2019 c'est pour aller vers
plus de parité que des ateliers dédiés
sont organisées à la cité des métiers de
saint quentin en yvelines ils sont
proposés par laure olivier qui a lancé
son organisme de formation dans
l'agglomération l'objectif trouver son
projet entrepreneurial une grande
opération de recrutement 50 postes
d'auxiliaires de vie sont à pourvoir
dans les yvelines en 2022 petit fils va
embaucher 30 personnes pour l' agence de
versailles 20 à voisins le bretonneux et
des journées portes ouvertes sont
organisées les 9 et 11 février et puis
ça se rapproche et j moins un avant le
quart de finale de coupe de france de
football bergerac versailles coup
d'envoi demain à 18h30 côté staff on
prépare le déplacement des joueurs pour
la rencontre qui se jouera à périgueux
en dordogne
immersion une autre rencontre dans ce
journal qui se prépare celle entre le
lycée hoche et sainte-geneviève 7 à
versailles auch contre ginette c'est du
basket et on en parle tout à l'heure
[Musique]
mais avant de développer ses titres
j'accueille tout de suite en plateau mon
invité leurs oliviers bonsoir et merci
d'être avec nous un plateau vous est la
fondatrice doivent ses créations
d'entreprises d'un organisme de
formation est dédié à l'entrepreneuriat
féminin il a été créé dans
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines en 2021 alors ce matin je le
disais dans les titres vous proposiez un
atelier trouvé son projet
entrepreneurial en cette étape c'était à
la cité des métiers de saint quentin en
yvelines qui est située à trac on va en
parler dans un instant revenons déjà sur
votre histoire votre histoire
personnelle vous avez exercé dans la
fonction publique pendant dix ans avant
de prendre la direction stratégique et
commerciale et d'une entreprise de
terrassement dans les yvelines ça
c'était en 2017 et pour ce faire vous
avez dû reprendre vos études pour à
distance incité ses études d'ailleurs
pour vous investir totalement dans ce
nouveau rôle d'entrepreneur l'a en
quelque sorte d'être passés de l'autre
côté dans le rôle de formateur pourquoi
ua
avoir eu envie de transmettre ce goût
pour la création d'entreprise justement
donc l'idée c'est qu'en fait pendant
trois ans donc j'ai occupé donc je suis
passé du monde public au monde privé
donc vraiment le grand le grand saut
l'idée en fait j'ai vraiment occupé une
fonction de direction d'entreprises où
je suis passé par les étapes de création
de gestion et notamment
en faisant appel en fait un certain
nombre de compétences que j'ai dû
développer en autodidacte ce fut c'est
quand même un changement radical et ça
m'a amené qu'on a une
à transmettre en fait c'est l'écho les
compétences que j'ai développée dans le
cadre de l'entrepreneuriat puisque moi
dans mon background j'ai occupé une
fonction
au cnfpt donc c'était un organisme
public lié à la formation
professionnelle des fonctionnaires déjà
volet formation dans votre cursus dans
mon professeur de la formation
professionnelle et en fait je me suis
autorisée en fait à occuper et à créer
un centre de formation plutôt dédié aux
femmes puisque moi j'ai connu tout ce
parcours entrepreneurial au féminin et
c'est vrai que c'est quand même une
faire face à ces croyances limitantes et
à rebondir et ilyas autorisé à prendre
une direction la direction d'une
entreprise notamment l'enjeu d'un
chiffre tout à l'heure dans les titres
40 % des créateurs d'entreprises en
france en 2010 neuf étaient des femmes
on n'est pas encore tout à fait la
parité mais on s'en rapproche il ya du
progrès ce c'est important de donner un
coup de pouce justement à ces femmes qui
est bien ambitionne dans ce projet inde
avant un projet de création d'entreprise
là aujourd'hui c'est vrai que
l'entrepreneuriat féminin progresse on
est on est on est quasiment à l'égalité
on peut l'entendre au niveau de
l'entrepreneuriat ce qui est un peu
étonnant c'est qu'en fait ce qu'on
considère sur l'emprunt féminin c'est
que il n'ya que 72% des femmes qui
en fait les 72 % des femmes sont
diplômés hauteur sont extrêmement
diplômés et en fait on on aperçoit que
l'entrepreneuriat féminin est un peu
réservés à des femmes qui sont
extrêmement diplômés et moi mon approche
c'est vraiment de démocratiser
l'entreprenariat féminin et de me mettre
à disposition de toutes les femmes
salariées qui ont qui sont dotés d'une
expertise métier et là aujourd'hui moi
je les accompagne dans ce parcours là
donc un peu sur mesure on dispose d'un
dispositif de formation qui est
développée
à travers une plateforme de formation et
des séances individuelles de coaching
donc toujours le dispositif se fait à
distance et ça permet aux femmes
salariées de lancer leur projet
entrepreneurial tout en conservant leur
entreprise leur activité salariée et
qu'est ce qui freine encore aujourd'hui
justement la création d'entreprise pour
pour ces femmes on imagine que la
période et n'aide pas ces sanitaires
mais quels sont les freins je pense que
là le frein principal c'est je manque
lui aussi de danser un peu de nous mêmes
c'est à dire qu'on est on ne se sent pas
capable de prendre la direction d'une
entreprise on s'autorise pas à
apprendre des risques à faire preuve
d'audace et a lancé des actions de
prospection pour développer son activité
on je pense qu'il ya une partie de
barrières mentales qu'on a toutes un peu
oui qu'on s'est auto créé je pense
d'autant qu' on regarde les chiffres de
certaines études les femmes s'avérerait
plus performantes que les hommes dans la
gestion d'entreprises
les sociétés sera en moyenne 8% plus
rentable quand actions géré par des
femmes bah c'est ce qu'on observe donc
je pense qu'effectivement il ya une part
d'investissement les femmes sont plus
investis sur la partie fiscale et la
partie comptable l'analyse financière je
pense que ça fait partie des qualités et
puis les femmes problème peut-être moins
de risque beaucoup du coup elles
investissent peut-être plus sur vos
instincts et elles portent leur
entreprise
en termes de rentabilité effectivement
elles paraissent plus efficace et
performante à l'atelier de ce matin je
le disais trouver votre projet
entrepreneurial en cette étape c'était
donc la première ce matin il y aura un
autre atelier le 15 mars de 18 heures à
20 heures toujours à la cité des métiers
pourquoi cette étape j'ai envie de vous
poser la question parce que c'est un
processus c'est à dire qu'on va partir
sur des outils de coaching où on m'a
accompagné la femme qui est salarié qui
a une envie d'entreprendre mais pour
autant qu'il n'y a pas forcément
s'autoriser à se lancer donc on a besoin
de passer par des incertains processus
pour l'accompagner vers des outils donc
on va utiliser les outils de de
développement personnel parce que ça
nous permet en fait de d'évacuer ses
pensées un paralysante et un peu
négative qui nous concerne je pense tout
de méditation notamment où est la
méditation les exercices de
visualisation aussi ça vous permet de
sortir en fait de votre contexte présent
et d'essayer de d'imaginer que votre
futur il peut aussi être entrepreneuriat
on en revient ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure c'est lever les barrières
finalement et mentale un peu raide vrai
obstacle pour s'autoriser à créer sa
boîte et puis à vivre de son activité
entrepreneuriale est une chose
importante alors qui nous paraît logique
c'est avant de se lancer dans ce projet
il faut identifier ses talents pour bien
définir justement le projet de vers
lequel on veut se diriger oui on utilise
les un outil alors l'appel i qui gavent
et lee qui gagne c'est le croisement de
vos missions actuelles donc de vos des
missions que vous occupez aujourd'hui de
ce qui vous permet en fait de faim ce
que les gens disent de vous donc vous
êtes doué dans un certain vous avez des
savoirs est et des savoir-faire que vous
pouvez restituer dans votre expérience
entrepreneuriale et puis vous avez aussi
le l'idée que vous avez des besoins et
des valeurs que vous les portez au monde
et tout ça ça nous amène à a ciblé un
projet entrepreneurial que vous pouvez
porter est donc aussi une autre étape la
dernière qu'on peut citer par exemple
c'est identifier ces trois supers
pouvoirs
les trois sous terre pour voir baisser
ça s'est extrait de votre vie qui gagne
c'est que vous êtes capable en fait de
déterminer que vous avez des qualités de
négociation parce que vous savez dans
votre vie perso et professionnels vous
les avez utilisé que naturellement vous
le faites donc ça fait partie de vos
super potvin et ça c'est des call it
c'est un super coureur que pour vous
restituer dans votre activité
entrepreneuriale donc ça peut être aussi
la prospection la vente c'est des
activités qu'on ne peut identifier pas
forcément dans l'activité salariale mais
pour autant qui est une brave est une
vraie plus-value quand vous la portez
sur le domaine entrepreneuriat
d'ailleurs question comment s'inscrire
ça dure deux heures c'est de l' échange
on s'inscrit comment d'ailleurs vous
contacter la cité des métiers la cité
des métiers s'occupe des inscriptions
donc là la prochaine séance elle aura
lieu le 15 mars à en visioconférence
pour justement cibler les femmes
salariées qui n'ont pas la possibilité
de
devenir la cité des métiers sur leur
temps de travail est donc sûr
un système d'after work c'est à dire qu
en visioconférence vous accédez à la à
l'atelier de 18 heures à 20 heures le 15
ans et donc toutes les informations pour
justement s'inscrire qui qui s'affiche
en bas de l'écran merci leurs oliviers
d'avoir été avec nous et je rappelle
vous êtes à la tête du fc création
entreprise et vous le rappeliez le
prochain atelier aura lieu le 15 mars à
la cité des métiers de saint quentin en
yvelines avant de parler d'autre chose
focus sur une femme qui s'est justement
lancer dans l'entrepreneuriat c'est
l'histoire d'une belle rencontre sarah
scellier a repris les sycomore à
versailles alain l'ex gérant de
l'atelier de restauration aux mots de
mobilier et ancien expert la forme
depuis un an pour lui céder son activité
la jeune entrepreneur et est soutenu
dans son projet de reprise le reportage
de justin brasier
[Musique]
j'ai tout est chez moi à metz puisque
pour une opportunité comme celle ci il
faut photo quitté en faut partir parce
que vous êtes question sarah celi et la
nouvelle gérante des sycomores l'atelier
de restauration de meubles anciens est
installé depuis une douzaine d'années
rue du maréchal gallieni à versailles
elle-même restauratrice de mobilier
ancien et d'objets d'art elle a envoyé
sa candidature pour poursuivre
l'activité
c'est le seul qui m'a répondu j'avais
envoyé six ou sept courriers en pleine
pandémie donc c'était un peu compliqué
et en fait c'est le seul qui m'a répondu
et il m'a expliqué que lui me
proposerait pas un poste d'employé mais
il proposerait son poste à lui donc
gérants sont ceux
qui en veut qui et quel avenir comme
tous les jours et qui semble être ils
ont eu dans mon sens ancien expert à
l'insead aujourd'hui son atelier content
de pouvoir faire perdurer son activité
il lui transmet son savoir faire depuis
un an c'est elle qui prend les
rendez-vous qui je vais encore avec elle
voir les clients pour que l es s'habitue
à voir l'importance du travail pour
telle ou telle chose qu'elle puisse
ensuite faire les estimations de vie
existent et on s'entend très bien
en tant qu'entrepreneur sahara était
accompagné dans son projet par la
chambre des métiers et de l'artisanat de
versailles j'ai pas eue j'ai pas eu un
parcours semé d'embûches mais par contre
il faut en vouloir parce qu'il faut
avoir une fois être dynamique voire
d'énergie parce que donc c'est un mois
ça a pris quasiment et un an
sur place on trouve de tout des objets
d'exception de style ou d'époque comme
ce baromètre du xviiie siècle en bois
doré ce cartel du xviie siècle ou encore
cette commode régence ou d'époque
[Musique]
un métier qui a retué en passionnant
parce qu'en fait on s'ennuie jamais on
fait jamais les mêmes choses on
travaille jamais sur les
même pièce c'est passionnant et à chaque
fois on est obligé de trouver des
solutions différentes des méthodes de
travail différentes pour chaque problème
les meubles à restaurer viennent de
particuliers ou d'institutions comme le
château de versailles
[Musique]
un métier qui embauchent en ce moment
dans le département celui de la garde
d'enfants à domicile le baby sitting les
agences babychou de versailles
saint-germain-en-laye maisons laffitte
recrute 300 salariés 200 cdi sans
alternant pour la rentrée de septembre
2022 qui préparent le diplôme de ces
apps et accompagnement éducatif petite
enfance les offres d'emploi sont à
consulter toute l'année sur le site
internet qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
et les entretiens se déroulent en
présentiel directement dans les agences
autre métier qui a des besoins de
recrutement celui d'auxiliaire de vie en
2050 près de 4,8 millions de français
seront en situation de dépendance et des
personnes âgées pour beaucoup qui ne
souhaitent pas aller en maison de
retraite mais bien rester chez elle à
domicile et depuis 2010 est l'agent ce
petit fils met en relation client et
auxiliaires de vie les précisions dans
ce reportage de mélanie poker comme je
sors je passe bien comme provisions
alors vous avez du
cheikh de saucisse purée au bien filer
comme chaque jour okaya cei est aux
petits soins de madeleine lambert 7
versaillaise fait appel depuis cinq ans
à la société petit fils pour quatre
jours par semaine âgée de 98 ans il est
hors de question de quitter son
appartement son lieu de vie depuis 1970
vu que j'approche deschamps temps j'ai
beaucoup de choses je suis obligé tout
seul
j'ai besoin d'avoir quelqu'un avec moi
on m'apporte beaucoup on rigole bien
ensemble
voilà et puis c'était une compagnie très
grave
voilà peut pas dire milieu
du mardi au vendredi de 9h à 21h rokhaya
et l'auxiliaire de vie de madeleine son
nom le gardien comme elle la qualifie
elles ont leurs petites habitudes et à
les choses qu'on a mis en place oui
parce que des fois il ya les oublie
après une première carrière dans la
vente rokhaya se lance dans le métier il
ya dix ans préparation des repas
toilette déjeuner à 2 ou encore les
courses c'est que j'aime d'un sommet qui
s'est fait servir il faut donner
ce que j'ai aimé avec un petit fils
c'est parce que on vous donne pas
plusieurs personnes donc on a une
personne ou deux personnes ça c'est plus
intéressant oui quand je prends mes
vacances aussi j'appelle
je gère un peu à distance
voilà que les habitudes et tout ça mais
ses enfants aussi sont très gentils elle
a toute la famille or aux cayes a été
recruté par petit-fils trois agences
existent dans le département comme celle
de voisins-le-bretonneux qui accompagne
plus de 90 familles l'équipe cherche 20
nouveaux auxiliaires à temps plein le
but des auxiliaires de vie quand elles
vont intervenir à domicile c'est d'aider
à faire et pas de faire à la place de le
but c'est bien de maintenir l'autonomie
est pas delà de remplacer tout ce que
fait la personne les auxiliaires de vie
elles vont pas avoir de petites missions
on privilégie vraiment la qualité du de
leur métier en fait donc elles vont
alors que des grosses missions les temps
de trajet qui vont être assez court
entre chaque chaque employeur qu'ils
auront et surtout depuis le 1er janvier
2022 on a cherché à revaloriser leurs
salaires la rémunération 13 euros 70
brut de l'heure en semaine 16 euros 40
les week-ends petit fils propose aussi
un accompagnement pour un public en
situation de handicap
deux journées portes ouvertes seront
d'ailleurs proposées demain mercredi 9
février aussi vendredi 11 février dans
les agences de versailles et deux
voisins le bretonneux
la campagne pour l'élection
présidentielle bat son plein et
notamment dans les yvelines jeudi
dernier michel barnier ancien candidat à
la primaire les républicains actuel
conseiller de valérie pécresse était
présent à une réunion soutien au vésinet
un rendez vous auquel ont assisté de
nombreux élus locaux du territoire qui
pour certains font même partie de
l'équipe de campagne de la candidate
écoutez ses propos recueillis par
justine brasier et patrick jacques de
dixmude ya deux campagnes à campagne que
valérie pécresse mène partout en se
déplaçant une campagne aussi très
médiatique au niveau national et après
il faut que nous tous ses soutiens ses
porte parole on se dit multiplient
partout en s'appuyant sur nos élus
locaux c'est ça notre force mon soutien
ne fait aucun doute je l'ait annoncé à
très longtemps puisque j'étais à ses
côtés lors du congrès à ses côtés depuis
très longtemps moi je suis très fier
j'étais même émue cette semaine en
signant le papier du conseil
constitutionnel pour apporter mon
parrainage studieux je pense qu'il ya
encore un long chemin avec beaucoup de
travail et qu'il nous faut convaincre
les français du sérieux de nos
propositions ils ont été un peu échaudé
ces dernières années
sur les promesses déjà et des autres les
élections présidentielles se tiendront
les 10 et 24 avril prochains du
mouvement au conseil municipal de
trappes avec deux défections au sein du
principal groupe d'opposition guy
malandain et mustapha larbaoui
deviennent élus indépendants annonce
faite ce lundi soir lors du dernier
conseil municipal joint par téléphone
les deux hommes justifie cette décision
par une volonté de reprendre leur
liberté est confiée en l'absence de
tensions au sein du groupe une décision
provisoire jusqu'à la fin juin pour
l'ancien maire de gauche guy malandain
en vue des prochaines échéances
électorales et ce pour donner sa
préférence en toute liberté pour rappel
il s'était allié à son ancien opposant
de droite othman nassr ou lors de la
dernière municipale partielle à trappes
pour mustapha larbaoui en revanche la
décision est définitive l'ancien
président du club de football de la
ville ayé d'hotman nasri depuis 2020 se
dit lassé des étiquettes et des conflits
politiques il souhaitant revenir je cite
à sa singularité
celle d'un élu issu de la société civile
le sport j moins un avant le quart de
finale de la coupe de france de football
bergerac versailles la rencontre se
disputera ce mercredi à 18h30 à
périgueux un déplacement qui a à donner
quelques maux de tête aux organisateurs
versaillais qui ont dû s'organiser
rapidement miquel et demi d'euros et
bixente n'a rien senti steban lundi 31
janvier le fc versailles 78 ans qui
jouera son quart de finale de coupe de
france à l'extérieur face à bergerac une
autre équipe de nationale 2 le tirage au
sort à peine effectuée le staff s'est
précipité pour préparer ce déplacement
inédit qui se jouera sur la pelouse du
stade francis rongiéras ca périgueux ça
se prépare vite surtout parce qu'entre
le tirage au sort et et
le jour du maintien très peu de temps
donc il faut vite être être réactif
faire toute la logistique pour pour
l'équipe première déjà pour le
déplacement et puis après c'est de voir
ce qu'il est possible de faire pour pour
nos supporters pour optimiser les
chances de victoire pour l'équipe et ne
pas accumuler de la fatigue le staff
organisée minutieusement le premier
quart de finale de l'histoire du club
départ en train jusqu'à bordeaux et à
bordeaux il y aura un train et un car
qui viendra nous nous récupérer pour
nous emmener jusqu'à périgueux où on a
on a réservé l'hôtel
on s'entraînera
s'entraînera sur un terrain voisin le
jour du match le matin du match on
repartira juste après le match à
bordeaux on dormira avant de reprendre
le train pour rentrer jeudi matin au
total le contingent devrait se composer
d'une trentaine de personnes tout le
staff pas tout l'effectif non
non non ce qu'ils vont être choisis par
par le coach bien sûr et puis certains
accompagnant on est mais on n'est pas
très nombreux à nous dans la structure
des fêtes du club donc
oui non ce sera une délégation légère
mais suffisante
du côté des supporters un quart va
partir pour la rencontre ce mercredi 9
février à 9h30 direction périgueux une
victoire de versailles dans le sud-ouest
permettrait de mieux digérer les 14
heures de bus aller-retour qui sont au
programme de ce déplacement
et nous vous ferons vivre de l'intérieur
cet événement unique événement premier
événement pour les yvelines et pour les
versaillais demain tout au long de la
journée sur nos réseaux sociaux des
publications et à 18h l'avant match de
cette rencontre au sommet aller vers ça
et bien sûr on va se mouiller quand même
pour ce match toujours à versailles les
lycée sainte-geneviève et auch vont
s'affronter lors d'un match de basket ce
sera le 17 février prochain un événement
très attendu par les étudiants des deux
établissements de nouveau michael et
demi d'euros avec arthur le golvan
un match de basket avec des étudiants
chauffé à blanc dans une salle pleine à
craquer après deux ans d'absence le
sulfureux derby ginette auch sera de
retour le 17 février prochain ce rendez
vous entre les deux lycées versailles a
été imaginé par françois allaman
professeur de sport au lycée
sainte-geneviève j'ai créé un petit
match entre élèves à 10 personnes dans
un gymnase 2004 et petit à petit ça a
pris de l'ampleur quelque chose en plus
quelques enceinte en plus 300 500 800
900 personnes et après on est parti sur
mont boron pour une machine importante
aujourd'hui l'événement regroupe
plusieurs centaines d'étudiants sur une
soirée au gymnase mot bron avec en jeu
bien plus qu'un match le basket mais une
suprématie c'est un oxford cambridge
pardonnez moi
cette référence à la sauce nba
sur deux entités qui se connaissent
depuis des dizaines voire plus années et
qui ont envie ce moment-là de de
participer à une grande joute sportive
basket
le spectacle sera également autour du
terrain au programme des shows de pom
pom girls un dj ou encore des vip dans
les tribunes c'est une folle ambiance
qui surprend même les joueurs de
l'équipe de france qui sont venus de
basket ça n'existe pas aujourd'hui dans
le milieu professionnel et c'est ce qui
nous surprend tous encore chaque année
le match est uniquement sur invitation
pour les spectateurs venus de
l'extérieur pour l'instant ginette
domine ce derby avec 14 victoires pour
une seule défaite
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité dans un instant vous
retrouver à célia de son goût et le 7-8
culture qui parlera notamment du street
art qui s'est emparée de la ville de
chatou belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]